ah
reject okay so I'm missing my notes and
it's the first time I've ever done this
talk this could be interesting so first
and foremost I'm no I'm no expert on
health or fitness or anything like that
yeah I'm thin but that's not everything
and that's probably more luck than
anything else but after many years being
a working development it's just a topic
that I've wanted to help people with and
to be honest with you in Germany
probably far better than developers I've
met in other countries so not all of
this will apply but some of it hopefully
so every day as a developer we're
generally checking news keeping up to
date with news and updates that's
happening in in the areas were working
in we're keeping an eye on issues and
handling them and replying to them we're
taking care of pull requests and
commenting and interacting with people
on those we may be helping out on things
like stackoverflow and other forums to
help other developers who are learning
and having problems we may be attending
and speaking at meetups and other events
and maybe we're writing proposals and
presenting at conferences as well this
is a lot of flexible of time and all of
this is also on top of a day job and
maybe for some people are family as well
this is quite a commitment quite a lot
of commitment here and a lot of people
outside the development community will
say things like don't you'll get paid
really well don't you will get amazing
benefits and work in really cool offices
and spend all day not really working
well this is a sometimes true
yes and not for everybody this only
tends to be some companies not all
companies and all developers and still
health is important you only get one try
at it within reason depending on beliefs
and luck and a combination of the two
maybe and whilst life is worth living in
the moment sometimes the moment can be
longer and more enjoyable if you're in
good health whilst doing it so let's
have a look at some issues and I have
some facts and figures in my notes that
I can't currently see so I may have to
do a bit of really annoying switching
back with the forwards because when
giving facts and figures you want to
give the rightfax of figures so this
might be slightly annoying but we'll see
what happens so typical developer
environment here and another one and
another one apart from this last picture
where there's someone breaking my rules
but they're the best pictures I could
find everyone's sitting down as are most
of you now as well this isn't new this
debate and it will sort of up and down
whether it really is or it really isn't
and but I think now most people are in
fairly strong agreement that it is if we
all do it way too much and if you want
to read a little bit more detail on this
it's a discussion it was mainly had a
couple of years ago there's this oops no
not that that article on the Washington
Post that has a really graphic as well
but I've picked some facts here from the
NHS they seemed as the British National
Health Service seem to be better than
picking them from an article or some
untrusted blog NHS does seem vaguely
more trustworthy so there's lots of
problems we're sitting down too much
and we are all doing it way too much and
this isn't common or unique to
development community of course all jobs
now or most jobs now a sedentary and
involve using computers and trying to do
anything else apart from sit down all
day is quite difficult and of course
we're always ahead of most and on the
cutting edge in the development
community so we've come up with ideas
like standing desks and actually I want
to point out in most i've picked it in
some of these pictures intentionally
because so this person has a standing
desk but there is a stool behind and
he's actually standing all day is also
not very good for you so um the secret
is actually variety really a bit of
sitting a bit of standing a bit of
moving maybe sitting in a few different
places giving your body a surprise and
something new experiences on a regular
basis is actually possibly the best
thing to do and here's some other
examples so in this picture we have some
normal desks and we have some standing
desk towards the back and these are
becoming more and more common in all
workplaces which is really good and
here's another good example of a sort of
similar mixed office the strange thing
is though it's more of a cultural thing
in that I found I go to events quite
often and I like to stand up I've been
sat down all day and you stand up at the
back and people are really awkward about
it they always think you're
uncomfortable or there's not enough
chairs or say it's a strange thing that
we all know that it's bad for us and yet
when you try to not do it people are
really uncomfortable about it so it's a
the cultural shift has changed in that
we know we should do it so much but it's
still seen as an odd thing to do and
which is strange and yeah I still
challenge whether you can get as much
done standing up or sitting down it's
slightly harder and you also notice as
we'll come to in a minute it's hard to
get posture right as well
so it's a tough one but we're it's it's
something that more people are open to
investigating okay let's get a bit more
extreme walking disks this is it's
actually become a popular as well less
so in Europe and these are
professionally available ones I've never
been to an office like this this is
quite incredible and these are very
expensive and you can get some more DIY
options like this and there's plenty of
tutorials on this and this is actually a
friend of mine in Croatia this is one he
has and I know a guy in Friedrichs rain
who's done something very similar and as
again you can see you can actually add a
chair to it and both the people i know
who do this are incredibly thin and look
like rakes I don't know if that's good
or bad but but so but again variety is
kind of the spice of life as we say and
there's many ways and things to try now
so posture we already had a quick look
at that this is a very traditional sort
of look at bad posture and coding
especially is one of those activities
you sit there you're concentrating on
something and in four hours later you
realize you've been SAT like this not
quite like this because I'm standing up
but for about four hours with your back
like that and your arms like that and
you suddenly think Oh God what about
done to myself and it's very hard to not
to it's very hard to avoid these habits
sometimes and we all know that we should
sit straight relax muscles arm 90
degrees and things like that but when
you're concentrating it's quite
difficult to concentrate on anything
else and I have a more amusing picture
there but and again posture is something
that isn't new there's plenty of advice
out there on things to try and
especially in Czech workspaces I think
we tend to get better setups but often
there's also a conscious decision for
you to try and sit better as well and
again bad posture can
arm things like blood flow back problems
of course and as you get older it gets
worse and I work on computers I ride a
bike I used to play guitar none of those
are good for your posture at all because
you always like that the whole time so
try it's hard work but try okay exercise
now I don't go to a gym I personally
think Jim's are just a an excuse for to
get money out of you can get exercise in
other ways as well but and this is some
advice that I want to to give simple
simple things you can try yeah this is
probably the when you try to find
pictures about exercise you end up
finding there's lots of pictures of
unrealistic looking people and looking
very happy with themselves this is about
the best I could most realistic picture
I could find about exercise and again
I'm missing my facts and figures
unfortunately but we all know that a
lack of exercise mixed with sedentary
lifestyles can cause weight gain blood
flow problems heart problems leg issues
back issues etc etc and not proposing
anything particularly difficult here we
have some very simple solutions of
things just to get some exercise take a
short walk every hour also gives you a
good screen break I think opinion on
whether looking at screens all day long
is bad for our eyes has changed somewhat
but certainly it's good to get up from
your desk for reasons we've already seen
walking meetings I don't know about you
but I'm actually a my most inspired when
I'm walking and if I could well I can
walk and work we've already looked at
that but but if I could walk more during
my day I think I would have a lot better
ideas the blood gets pumping and you get
some amazing ideas so we have stand-ups
what about walkouts now that sounds a
bit too extreme but do some other ideas
stand up every hour there we go that's
another one we know the Apple watch is a
bit enthusiastic about telling us to do
that but you get the idea
take the stairs again this is actually
far more regular in in Germany than
other countries I've lived in and in
fact half the time there's not even the
lift so you have no excuse and walk or
ride to work if possible in fact even if
you get public transport you're
generally getting more exercise and
driving just by virtue of walking two
stops usually standing up walking from a
stop to your office and things like that
and of course if you work from home you
have to try even harder with some of
these things easy running high impact
running if you're out of shape is
probably going to do you more harm than
good but even ten minutes a day is
better than nothing or brisk walk if
you're like swimming swimming is not
only good for your fitness is also good
for lung capacity if you have problems
like asthma and things like that you
don't have to if you're a little bit
overweight or you have bad feet it's
also good because you're not relying on
them so something like swimming is very
good mental health now this is probably
one that actually gets over looks more
because it's harder to see so it's sort
of undecided whether whilst the brain is
one of the actually one of the biggest
and any of your friends who have fitness
fans will try and tell you otherwise the
brain is actually the biggest consumer
of energy in your body it consumes
twenty percent of the energy that you
bring into your body which considering
how much space it takes up in your body
is quite amazing it's unproven as of now
whether if you do more intellectual
activity you require more energy it's
sort of some reports say yes and some
say no it's sort of one that is
currently being looked at quite a lot
but those periods of constant focus
those periods of constantly thinking put
strain on you in other ways whether or
not it's actually consuming more energy
or not as I say is controversial but
you're still the focus is tiring this is
not that it's not the best
representation of what I was looking for
but this is talking about the isolation
of Technology and
for a lot of us in this room who will
probably picked on at school and had a
horrible time and if you were a child of
the 80s splash early 90s there was no
real escape from that world now there's
an escape you can find people who are
like you anywhere in the world and it's
it's been empowering for many but it
also cuts you off from the world around
you and this especially if you work from
home or work in distributed teams is is
it is something to be conscious of and I
find myself getting less or more
oblivious to what's going on around me
and the feelings of people around me
sometimes and we're all doing it more
and if you've noticed in the past 10
years no one looks where they're going
anymore because we're so used to being
in our own world and that can lead to
side effects as well so here's some
ideas to try to help with that isolation
of working with lots of working with
technology but also that mental strain
and we'll come to some of the
consequences of that mental strain in a
minute but here's some things to try to
prevent getting it in the first place go
for a walk you could tell I like walks
it's good for you speak to someone you
don't work with and whether that be in
your company or outside of the company
speak to the person you get your coffee
from speak to someone random on the
street it'll probably surprised the hell
out of them but they'll make their day
as well hopefully the petty where the
conversation goes speak to a stranger
yeah for social actions this is this is
one that's possibly harder for us
sometimes it's easy to retreat into your
own world and we've already done I find
myself doing that i find myself avoiding
conflicts because i don't really why
would i want to go into them but
sometimes the outcome can be far better
than you expect and actually what you
were worried about resolves itself in a
more positive way anyway so try to force
yourself into a difficult situation
you're trying to avoid on a reasonably
regular basis is also good for your
brain as well in things like
elasticity in your brain attend events I
don't really have to tell that to anyone
here you're all under vent so but to the
people out there attended event
volunteer be it in a related field or
unrelated field is a great way of
getting out of your mental space
realizing sometimes depending where
you're volunteering that the problems
you think you have are not as big as
problems other people have as well and
it's a great invigorate ER for your
mental health take a nap I don't know
why the northern hemisphere or northern
countries are so obsessed with starting
work at a particular time taking a short
break finishing a particular time and
then running away as soon as possible a
lot of other countries especially the
warmer countries will take siestas naps
whatever you want to call it and there's
been many exam
I have been ignoring that for quite a
while it's probably laughing later I'm
not gonna do live demo is a bad enough
let alone live update and it's been well
proven that many people believed in
taking short naps I we know famous
historical examples like Napoleon and
Churchill I they're probably less
realistic people to look at but um I
used to work especially people from
countries like China and Japan are
amazing at just napping and if you've
ever been to any of those countries
you'll see people just having a nap and
I used to work with a guy in back in
Melbourne in Australia who would after
lunch with the city's desk take a nap
and it's actually great view I can't do
it personally but it's great for your
brain it really invigorates you and
again a lot of these bits of advice I'm
trying to give are reliant on being in a
workplace that will encourage and allow
you to do these things and not think oh
my god they're sleeping on the job who
is this idiot but yeah but try it try
some of these things meditation again I
I like kind of being uptight so I I
don't find meditation a very easy thing
to do but I keep trying and I know it's
good for me but I'm not saying I do
everything all these lists as I said
earlier this is alluding to again the
impact on your eyes of working late in
the dark just before you go to bed is
sort of contentious but certainly we're
aware that being switched on wherever we
consider that just mental activity or
literally switched on with the device
you should try to have about an hour
before you go to sleep switched off and
and again something like a kindle for
reading still is shown to not be as good
as just reading a book and I understand
we appreciate I travel a lot I
completely appreciate the convenience of
things like digital books but give it a
go try it listen to some music or
something like that sleep is by far one
of the most important things to get
right without good sleep it affects
pretty much all the other things we've
talked about now there we go I could see
why I doubt to what's coming next so
yeah all these things sleep helps so ah
even a little bit of strangely it sounds
like a contradiction but doing some
exercise before sleep can also help and
he's again were from the NHS MIT plus
many others here's an interesting one
I've kind of gone off on a slight
tangent in terms of mental health saying
no learning to say no knowing your
limits knowing your boundaries it's
often causes lots of the mental health
in the first place especially in our
field this is a favorite phrase of a
friend of mine I'll leave it up to you
to fill in the blanks and having clear
conversations and making sure we're not
assuming anything about anything can be
a good source of clearing up mental
stress in the long run if you don't have
time for a task in planning stand-ups
things like that say so I personally
feel like it's better to under-promise
and over-deliver than the other way
around if you don't understand something
ask no harm in it if you're
uncomfortable say so and we we read
event has a code of conduct that this
can also minimum or micro level we have
a problem say so don't let things sit
and bubble under the surface now we come
to diet because often when we're
stressed when we have mental health when
we're feeling down we overcompensate
with bad often eating drinking other
things I really wanted to come up here
and say Club Marta is bad for you but
actually isn't I was quite disappointed
it's the caffeine is about the same as a
cup of coffee or the sugar is really low
so keep drinking
it's okay just not too many so we'll
leave that one alone pizza how many
events do we go to where the catering is
pizza and pizza actually went down well
with certain ingredients and not too
much cheese not too much salt isn't too
bad but we can't guarantee that that's
what we're getting so you know
moderation I like a slice of pizza but
moderation or suggest to meetup
organizers they try something else more
of that later okay I thought this would
make you love it really exists so whilst
Marte is not too bad other energy drinks
are terrible Coca Cola Cola actually pre
bad full of sugar full of all sorts of
stuff and a lot of the labeling on them
is misleading as well often the
ingredients you don't even what they are
so again in moderation everything in
moderation is ok but try not to have too
many mottos ok the alcohol I don't
really have to say much about the
negatives of alcohol we all know where
it can lead to when gone too far but we
also know that in our space with meetups
and certain offices is alcohol
everywhere and especially in Germany
it's cheap it's freely available Germans
are actually pretty good with alcohol
consumption comparison to I'm half
English half australian exposition I
cannot talk about alcohol but it's
always available and I love and often
for free where we are where we work so
you know be sensible now I'm going to do
a video next let's hope this works
no see no okay all right this was if
anyone could recognize from this fuzzy
image the IT crowd and where Jen takes
up smoking and in most countries in
Western world there are public smoking
bans and smoking now feels like you're
maligned Oh anyway so the likening isn't
now feeling like no okay too much beer
give the valium right I think it could
be like this most of time so I'll just
talk through it now smoking in most
Western countries is sort of felt like
you're an outcast in Germany not so much
but again we also know that smoking is
bad for us we don't have to you don't
mean me to tell you that but moderation
again if you're stressed you might be
smoking more try to solve the problems
of stress instead of just smoking more I
guess so here some things to try intact
instead of unhealthy snacks fruit in
moderation this event has fruit I see
lots of other events have fruit is great
nuts nuts could be can be fatty and
maybe have too much energy so again in
moderation especially certain sorts of
nuts and almonds almonds are terrible
for the environment so avoid those
especially they come from California
which is a place we're all very familiar
with and being tech people and they use
a lot of water in California is having
one of the worst droughts ever so avoid
almonds if you can for other reasons
water water is actually quite a good
appetite suppressant if you're hungry so
smoking but see previous slide healthy
snacks there's some solutions to this
and I'm going to forward you shortly to
someone who's far better expert on this
cook together often when you go out and
eat
take away restaurants are often over
salting seasoning putting extra fats et
cetera et cetera food was because really
why so cooking together at work is not
only a good activity again to introduce
that Mentos mental health positives but
also you're controlling what's going in
your food and you knowing what you're
eating going for a walk it's a good
distraction if you're hungry and I like
walking so um thanks very much now
there's something you know second oh
that's right yeah and that was very
corny wasn't it is so I have been to
developer for quite a long time but at
the moment actually work in developer
relations which is sort of why I come
into touch with a lot of um developers
and as part of that one thing I'm going
to be doing in the future is
collaborating with my my wife who in
Melbourne was a award-winning cooking
teacher and she's still doing some of
that here but we're actually going to
try running between the two of us as
part of other things healthy snacks and
catering for events take evades the
technate ups and things like that so we
have some healthy snacks available and I
can see at the back are they in the in
the tent yeah in the tent out the back
there's not enough for all of you and
you only have 10 minutes so go seriously
go now quick
reject